Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhasa Homage to the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So we're on number eight now of our perfections, our parami, those that take us to the other shore.
It's resolution, adhitana, A-D-H-I-T-T-H-A-N-A, just in case you want to know.
Tana means sort of position or place, your standing ground, and Adi just reinforces it.
resolute resolution enormous resolve this is mirrored in the Buddha's life just before he became fully liberated you remember the story he left home finding the household life had become empty because of this problem of meaninglessness
would have been expressed in those days as constant rebirth see constantly be having to come back and do the same thing all over again the same thing slightly different story but always you know being born growing up going old and dying and that constant constant thing is reincarnation so
He then went out to try and find an answer to this end of suffering, as he would call it, something hard to bear, unsatisfactoriness, a fundamental unsatisfactoriness.
And he tried all that business of developing absorption states, for they would disappear inside.
And he tried self-mortification, and it just got very thin.
And eventually he had that inspiration coming from childhood,
the way that child gets wrapped into something and yet has that curiosity so that was his inspiration and he went to sit under this tree what we now call the Bodhi tree, the fig tree the religious fig tree and he made a determination either to crack this problem or to die
that was the great determination and it took him six hours so it's mirrored in his life as that moment when he'd come to an end and he thought well either this is it or what's the point he was going to sit there until he dropped dead so
this comes as one of the great virtues and you have to make a distinction between an intention and the intentioned intention the English word has this double meaning of meaning a wish I have an intention to go and I intended to do it meaning that you actually made an act of will so that's why
We always make a distinction between the desire that arises and the empowerment of that desire.
These are two moments, see, two moments.
So even in simple things like, you know, a cup of tea, it comes up as a desire and nothing happens until you empower it.
Normally speaking, it's habitual, you know, we just go and do it.
But what meditation, what our mindfulness should do, daily mindfulness, is to make us more and more aware of these little intentions that come.
And then there's this power that goes into an intention.
That's your will.
And it's the will that takes something out of potential into actual.
So long as it remains a desire in the mind, nothing's happened.
But as soon as you empower it, something happens, either a train of thoughts or an action or speech.
One of the things happens.
And that's what we understand as a kama.
And the important thing is to know that this is how we condition ourselves, right?
Through these intentions.
Now, when an intention becomes, instead of habitual, something that you consciously make a decision about, right?
then you have to be resolute about that you have to really sort of contemplate why you want to do something and then you do it and of course there's always a little clause that stops you from going and taking it overboard except in exceptional circumstance or emergency
So you might determine to climb a mountain, see that corner there, where's the hill.
And as you get up and up and up, you might find that you're getting colder and colder and colder, you haven't put the right clothes on.
So in which case you have to come down because there's good reason.
But if you got up and up and you felt, well, I can't be bothered getting to the top, then that wouldn't be a wholesome reason.
See?
And slowly but surely by
by not completing your resolutions for good reasons you undermine your resolve you undermine your ability to commit yourself you never finish anything you know these people who say they can't finish anything see so you have to you have to be quite clear when you make a resolution that's what you're going to do this comes about also when even inadvertently you say you're going to help somebody and then you decide you don't want to do it
so you're undermining constantly your commitment in this case you're undermining your goodwill and the spiritual life to do that in the spiritual life is really undermining because if you say to yourself I'm going to sit here for six hours I'm going to sit here until I become fully enlightened or I'll drop dead or I die and you give up after half an hour that's bad news isn't it
Having made a rational decision that you are going to sit here for 40 minutes, you see, try to keep it.
Even if you're shifting and moving and doing all sorts of silly things, you keep to that resolve, you see.
And then there's that lovely feeling of having completed your commitment, you see.
I remember when I first started meditating in the Zen, you know, we were facing the wall, sitting on a bench, yeah?
I wasn't sitting cross-legged.
So it must have been, it wasn't very long I'd started, but the pain was excruciating in the knees and whatnot, you know, really quite painful.
But I was determined not to move.
I was absolutely, you know, Zen, you know?
You bang your head against the wall, that's what it's for.
That's why you sit next to the wall.
But I couldn't take it, you see.
And just as I gave up, the bell went.
Oh, I felt terrible.
Oh, never again, I said.
Never again will I give up on a resolve.
So, be careful.
So, you know, when you hear of people trying to overcome certain...
habits, certain addictions, you know, around smoking, eating, drinking and whatnot.
It's very difficult, you see.
And the more you don't keep your resolve, the more you undermine your ability to keep resolve.
So you have to really keep to your resolve.
Now, you won't keep to resolve if it's not a wise undertaking.
And what we mean by that is that it's something that you actually feel you can do.
There's no point in
you know, determining to climb Everest.
I mean, you've not done any training for it.
It's an absolute waste of time.
You just keep, like it's a Walter Mitty, isn't it?
So it has to be something that is rational, something that you know you can do, even if it takes just that little bit more effort.
But you keep the result.
And that's, of course, the same with things that are wholesome, too.
so after morning chanting here before we say you know before we make the final bounce I always ask people to make a resolution for the day this is more like a general resolve just to live mindfully with a good heart something very general you see now the problem with these
These resolves, of course, we keep forgetting.
So, as often as you can during the day, to keep reinforcing that resolve by just saying it, eventually becomes habitual.
When we take vows, such as marriage vows, I think people think that once you've had this big ceremony, you've made a vow, that's it, you don't have to worry about it anymore.
But the vow only lasts as long as the ceremony.
It might last a couple of days after that.
Then you get fed up with each other.
So it's a constant.
That's why, you know, when I've done these little things for people, I always say, you know, on your anniversary, you know, don't just go out and get drunk or something.
Actually use it to re-establish the vow.
And in that way, you keep reinforcing your commitment to the relationship.
So it's the same with a job.
Once you've undertaken a job,
ordinary work you know is that if you keep reinforcing your commitment to it you won't give in to silly things like boredom you know there won't be there'll be that constant empowering of your effort towards what you're doing I had somebody
email me just recently and they had found a way of being alive by doing something new but having done something new for so long it became habitual again and they went back into these old patterns of a lack of spontaneity in their lives and
What I pointed out to them was that it's your intention and your constant empowering of your intention to be with what you're doing in a completely whole-minded, whole-hearted way that turns it into a spontaneous action again.
So then he wrote back and he said, when I'm playing with my children
and he's got young kids, and he's actually in that sort of communication of being creative with them and all that, then these ideas of being habitual and lack of spontaneity disappear.
He said, is that what you mean?
I said, yes.
So this comes about by, you know, recognising what your intentions are, make sure they're wholesome, and then you just do it, you put yourself into it.
And that's one of this business of Adhitana, you see.
So this Adhitana, Resolute Resolution, is a real virtue to develop.
And it's a case of keeping to your resolve as best you can.
Making sure it's
within your power don't be sort of ridiculous about results and to make a determination to do it then you always say save an extraordinary circumstance or emergency and else you become foolhardy you sort of push yourself even when the whole situation is telling you that actually this resolve is not working it's not working anymore stop it
So I can only hope my words of being of some assistance and that by your resolute resolutions you will indeed come to the end of suffering sooner rather than later.